the World Economic Forum took place in
Davos over the last few days and a whole
bunch of interesting stuff came out of
it some really really interesting
commentaries about the situation in
Venezuela happened at which we may talk
about a little bit later in the week but
that's not what I want to talk about
today Michael Dell of Dell computers was
asked about his view on this idea
floated by congresswoman Alexandria
Casio Cortez to have a top marginal tax
rate of 70% and Michael Dell not
surprisingly said he doesn't support it
which is totally fine I mean he stands
to be taxed a lot with something like
that but he also claimed that it doesn't
work he actually says tell me someplace
where such a high top marginal tax rate
worked and I'm gonna play the video for
you and it is just so delightful to see
Michael Dell instantly schooled by MIT
professor Eric Erik Brynjolfsson who
explained that hold on a second it
actually has worked in the United States
and this is just so good let's take a
look at the entire moment from the panel
Michael Dell being asked the question
then saying well where has anything like
that worked and then the professor
explains to him well it's actually
worked in the United States where you've
built your business there are growing
calls to address these inequalities that
particularly the wage inequality with
more taxes in particular in the United
States there's been a call by
congresswoman Ocasio Cortes to tax
people earning over 10 million and a 70%
tax rate the current top rate United
States is 37 percent michael doe do you
support this I just want to say I'm
thrilled the dirt Wow
well look I mean you know my wife and I
set up a foundation about 20 years ago
and we would have contributed quite a
bit more than a 70 percent tax rate on
my income on my annual income and I feel
much more comfortable with our ability
as a private foundation to allocate
those funds than I do giving them to the
government all right I'm not supportive
of that and I don't think it would help
the growth of the US economy oh that's
interesting and can you say a little bit
more about why why you don't think I'll
name a country where that's worked ever
United States briefly in the eighties no
no from about the 1930s through about
the 1960s the tax rate averaged about 70
percent at times it was up as high as 95
percent and those were actually pretty
good years for growth so I don't have a
strong opinion on that proposal a lot
but the devil is in the details
but I think it's there's actually a lot
of economics that suggest that it's not
necessarily going to hurt growth yeah so
so let's talk about the facts right
because as Professor Brenda Wilson is
saying there he's not taking a position
on the particular proposal of Alexandra
Ocasio cortes which I don't even think
rises to the to the level of a proposal
she floated the idea of the 70 percent
top rate didn't even mention at what tax
bracket at what income level it would
kick in it is undeniably true regardless
of what your opinion is of such a tax
policy that the United States has a long
history of high top marginal tax rates
it doesn't mean that the government
takes 70 percent of tons of people's
money it means that very high earners
pay a high marginal tax rate only on the
income they earn above certain
thresholds it's also true that the US
has had many periods of growth and
prosperity and low unemployment while
they also had some of those high
marginal tax rates so it's not
incompatible to have economic prosperity
and
hi top marginal tax rates on very rich
people people with high income that's
not an argument about the morals and
ethics of such a proposal right you
could be for it or against it on a
number of different basis but what we
what we know is that we have had that
type of taxation in the US and it didn't
destroy the economy it's simply true
then you get to part two of the argument
which is that actually we can assess
whether that is a good policy for an
economy to put in place we know that
multiple studies point out that high
marginal tax rates on top earners are
good for the economy if your goal is to
maximize government revenue there are
many studies including one from MIT
among many but the MIT one is one that
we've looked at more closely which says
that 73% is the top marginal tax rate
where you maximize total tax revenue
taking into account that if you go up to
a hundred percent tax rate people stop
working right when you take into account
that other very high numbers can
incentivize people to leave the US and
try to find lower tax places to live or
whatever where you kick in that top tax
rate whether it should be at a million
five million 20 million whatever the
case may be that is more up for debate
and their different views on it and it
is really easy on this issue to get
different positions confused there's
whether we think it's right
morally to take from the rich okay we
can debate that then you get to the
actual economic issues one is has this
worked before the answer is yes it has I
mean quite it it just it has if the goal
is to maximize government revenue we
have some idea about what that top
marginal tax rate should be and it
should probably be in the low 70s the
most popular argument I've seen lately
against such a proposal is if you do
that rich people are going to leave the
country and the government is going to
lose out on all their tax revenue
because they won't be in the US and they
won't be paying taxes here anymore
that might be the case with some people
but the reality is that first of all if
you move out move out of the US you
don't just stop paying taxes okay a lot
of people don't understand this it's
complicated but if you're a US citizen
who earns much
from a u.s. corporation and you move
abroad you still have to file an
American tax return you still have to
pail to pay taxes you can reduce your
tax liability with things like the
foreign earned income exclusion with the
foreign housing deduction that exists
but most of these American rich people
mostly rich dudes they're not actually
ready to relinquish their US citizenship
assuming that they find another place to
get citizenship which is really the way
to stop paying taxes in the United
States so this wealthy flight horror
story that you hear from the right it's
just not super realistic in large
numbers and it also ignores the fact
that a lot of these rich people have
friends and family mostly in the United
States and even if they could avoid all
American taxes by going elsewhere not
all of them are going to abandon the one
place that they've lived their entire
lives where everyone they know lives so
it's merely a horror story that is not
realistic and it's not a good argument
for tax policy one way or the other but
Michael Dell just schooled in real-time
this is what should be done to Trump and
to sarah huckabee Sanders when they tout
these lies I just love it let me tell
you about today's sponsor zip recruiter
hiring can be very time-consuming you
post a job on a bunch of online job
boards you get a bunch of the wrong
resume resumes then you have to sort
through all of those resumes just to
find a few people with the right skills
and experience those job sites that
overwhelm you with the wrong resumes are
not smart the smart thing is to go to
zip recruiter dot-com slash Pakman
because unlike other job sites zip
recruiter finds qualified candidates for
you it's powerful matching technology
will scan thousands of resumes it will
identify people with the right skills
and education and experience and then it
will actively invite them to apply to
your job so that you actually get
qualified candidates quickly no wonder
zip recruiter is rated number one by
employers in the u.s. from hiring sites
on trust pilot with over a thousand
reviews
and right now my listeners and our
viewers can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter dot-com / Pakman and if you
love this show show your support and
show your support for zip recruiter by
going to zip recruiter dot-com slash PA
KMA and one more time that is zip
recruiter dot-com slash Pakman it's the
smartest way to hire